et met un bienfaiteur de l'humanité et
une enfance heureuse
c'est ici à biarritz que le professeur
emmett avec une enfance heureuse ses
parents venant parents arrière grands
parents cousins oncles ont consacré leur
vie à la science dont la grandeur à la
france et plus généralement le bien-être
de l'humanité
le professeur et met à rêver dès son
enfance d'un avenir radieux avec la
voiture volante
cette vision idyllique a été entachée
par le sort en effet plusieurs membres
de sa famille
inventeur comme lui sacrifiant leur vie
personnelle ont souffert dans leur chair
une histoire tragique alors qu'il
testait sa voiture of l'ongle au large
ans a disparu mystérieusement
la police a retrouvé son corps dans un
ravin le long des pyrénées
les autorités nous ont confié qu'ils
avaient ironie de l'histoire glissé sur
un nid de poule pour se vautrer comme
une omelette son cousin georges a connu
un destin tout aussi funeste
il pensait révolutionner l'automobile
avec les antennes un télescopique et le
cric automatique
il s'est fait électrocuter par la foudre
à bordeaux alors qu'il venait de crever
les services de médecine légale nous a
confié qu'il n'avait pas souffert
le cousin georges était en effet en
train de monter le volume de son
transistor sur une chanson de claude
françois
quand le drame est arrivé
une visite vers grande
[Musique]
malgré une histoire familiale
douloureuse
le professeur emmett n'a jamais cessé de
seriner vous les copains je ne vous
oublierai jamais soutenu par le
ministère de l'industrie français le
professeur emmett a réussi là où
d'aucuns avaient échoué il a brisé le
destin tragique qui pesait sur sa
famille après son double dr house
université étasunienne est mité et
stanford il a étudié plusieurs années
des travaux scientifiques de sa
vénérable ligne et pour mettre au point
la voiture volante avec l'énergie terme
aux éoliennes
une conséquence
tian un délai aujourd'hui le professeur
emmett peut être fier de l'oeuvre
accomplie il contemple maintenant la
cité basque depuis la lune ou les
satellites ont remplacé les mouettes
le professeur emmett peut s'adonner à
son loisir de prédilection le saut
increase désormais sur la mer de la
tranquillité sur l'astre lunaire
tout est à refaire un territoire à
coloniser les humanités peut compter sur
ses enfants et ses petits-enfants pour
poursuivre son ouvrage sur la gueule
elon lui a donné ce feu sacré la france
l'humanité peut dire merci au professeur
emmett musk un cocorico
[Musique]